fisica e biologia sono scienze molto
diverse
la fisica si occupa essenzialmente di
oggetti inanimati dagli atomi ai metalli
alle galassie invece la biologia si
occupa per definizione di ciò che è vivo
cioè di ciò che nasce si nutre cresce si
riproduce e muore
inoltre la fisica ricorre in modo
massiccio alla matematica ma anche se
molti non sarebbe d'accordo la fisica
cerca sempre la semplicità potrebbero
essere d'accordo con me il classico
studenti di fisica che davanti a un
problema preso dai calcoli
a un certo punto si dimentica pure cosa
stesse calcolando la realtà è così
l'ambizione di fisici e di descrivere un
ampia classe di fenomeni attraverso un
pugno di formule matematiche invece la
biologia si occupa dei sistemi complessi
perché anche la forma di vita più
semplice la cellula estremamente
complessa inutili essi 20 è come se
avessero uno scopo che la sopravvivenza
inoltre hanno una loro storia sia il
singolo individuo sia tutta la vita
dall'origine a oggi
e questo è proprio l'evoluzione ecco
parlando di evoluzione noi però potremmo
trovare un modo per mettere in contatto
queste due scienze ma non semplicemente
unendo le loro rispettive conoscenze ma
in modo più profondo
unendo le loro mentalità nel senso che
ci stanno alcuni concetti che hanno
valore universale
anche se con le diverse specificità che
possono essere molto utili per esempio
ben descrive l'evoluzione uno di questi
però è un concetto che sembra non
c'entrare niente con l'evoluzione che
quello di stabilità strano ma vero
partiremo dalla stabilità per arrivare
al cambiamento
parliamo di stabilità perché le specie
viventi sono sistemi stabili ma che vuol
dire specie i denti sono sistemi stabili
in realtà è una cosa semplicissima
se prendiamo due gatti un gatto e una
gatta e li facciamo accoppiare che cosa
genereranno dei gattini è una cosa ovvia
semplicissima dai gatti nascono i gatti
è proprio la definizione di specie cioè
quando due individui
che si possano accoppiare e la loro
prole è a nostra volta individui della
stessa specie
certo non si può negare che esista una
certa variabilità all'interno della
specie nel caso del gatto abbiamo
diversi tipi di pelo color e quello
degli occhi o addirittura diverse
tendenze comportamentali ma realtà
queste sono anche se includesse le
mutazioni la selezione dei cambiamenti
limitati al massimo delle fluttuazioni
ma allora un fisico quando vede delle
fluttuazioni ha davanti a sé un
oscillazione e a1 scilla zione può
associare una frequenza detta frequenza
propria è indicata matematicamente con
omega 0 e detta frequenza propria perché
dipende solo da caratteristiche
intrinseche della specie qui ho messo la
balenottera azzurra perché dopo
riprenderemo questo esempio
però ogni specie vivente si trova nel
suo habitat cioè l'ambiente e anche
l'ambiente è fatto di tantissime cose
che fruttano e cambiano un esempio è più
semplice abbiamo sotto gli occhi e
l'alternarsi del giorno e della notte
ma abbiamo anche nelle quattro stagioni
e tanti cicli a periodo più lungo
immaginiamo che da tutti questi
cambiamenti prendiamo un sottoinsieme
perché ci sono certi fattori ambientali
che hanno davvero un impatto importante
sulle specie cioè le cambiano in modo
considerevole senza passare per la
selezione naturale
consideriamo quindi questo sottoinsieme
attribuiamo di nuovo una frequenza che
stavolta chiamiamo omega e dove saprò
per esterna
a questo punto ci possiamo chiedere cosa
succede se questa particolare spiega
frequenza omega e fosse uguale a quella
dispiegata prima omega 0 accade quello
che un fisico chiama condizioni di
risonanza ma nel nostro contesto
possiamo chiamare condizione di
evoluzione sui cambiamenti si mettono ds
limitati ma diventano grandi forti
tantissimi neanche in un tempo
relativamente breve e questo nuovo modo
di descrivere tutto
l'ho chiamato teoria delle risonanze
evolutive o per brevità se preferite con
l'acronimo 3 l'acronimo non è casuale
così come l'immagine posta l'immagine è
un modo per dire in modo rapido
quante profondamente diverso questo con
questo modo di scrivere voluzione
rispetta
lo tradizionale ma anche tre un acronimo
simbolico perché questa teoria
rappresenta una terza strada tra il
marxismo e il darwinismo solo che prima
di procedere sarebbe meglio dire che
cos'è una risonanza e quindi prendiamo
un qualunque sistema che può stare
all'equilibrio ce l'abbia preparato
quando dico qualunque sistema intendo
veramente o qualunque sistema cioè anche
il mio caricabatteria in tutta la sua
bruttezza il caricabatterie normalmente
se lo tengo così è fermo sistema
l'equilibrio significa questo in
condizioni normali il sistema è fermo
non cambia configurazione non succede
niente seridò una piccola pizzica una
bottarella allora oscilla e la frequenza
con cui usciva dipende solo attacca
turistica intrinseche del mio sistema
cioè la lunghezza del filo la forma e la
distribuzione della massa non dipende da
se lo pizzicato ops ho soffiato si è
passato da calamita per questo è detto
frequenza propria
se però ho una forza esterna che non è
nemmeno grandissima preoccupante ed
oscillante la giusta frequenza c'è
uguale a quella propria allora
l'ampiezza del chill azione smette di
essere finita e diventa le principio
infinita cioè il sistema si fa a mettere
fermo e quindi un nuovo punto di
equilibrio stabile e nel nostro contesto
ogni punto di equilibrio corrisponde una
specie è questo salto che avete appena
visto corrisponde un salto evolutivo c'è
un grande cambiamento della specie e un
tempo relativamente breve
facciamo un esempio biologico la
balenottera azzurra è l'animale più
grande del mondo può arrivare fino a 33
metri di lunghezza questo bellissimo ma
mi fermano soltanto grande proprietà
intrinseche da studiare nella società ma
anche la sua storia evolutiva e
interessante sappiamo che iniziata dalla
terraferma quando verrà completamente
diverso ma ancora oggi ha diversi
problemi irrisolti
uno è proprio la sua lunghezza
nel senso che è stato pubblicato
quest'anno un articolo scientifico che
ha segnalato che l'antenato della balena
fino a due minuti anni fa avevano
lunghezza media sui 10 15 metri
che è poi diventato da quella attuale di
20 25 fino a 33 metri in soli 2 milioni
di anni 2000 e di anni possono sembrarci
tanto ma in realtà dal punto di vista
geologico e un tempo fin troppo breve e
quindi occorre una spiegazione perché
diventare praticamente il doppio non è
solo una questione di massa quando si
diventa così grande occorre un nuovo
sistema scheletrico un nuovo sistema
circolatorio con l'opportuno cuore ma
anche un nuovo sistema nervoso per fare
in modo che non sia troppo line da
trasmissione dell'impulso nervoso da una
parte all'altra del corpo
lo stesso articolo scientifico però
segnala che in questo intervallo di
tempo cioè due milioni di anni i più
recenti è iniziato un alternarsi di ere
glaciali e di e temperate e quindi
abbiamo un fattore esterno oscillante
con periodo basso chi può benissimo il
fatto risonanza con il periodo lungo di
cambiamento dei caratteri di una specie
come la balena e quindi è stata
soddisfatta la condizione di sanza e ho
avuto una divergenza nell'evoluzione con
una grande cambiamento in un tempo
relativamente breve
quindi adesso che abbiamo metabolizzato
un po la 3 proviamo a chiederci ok ma il
quadro complessivo a che cosa lo
possiamo paragonare ma anche questa
volta la possiamo paragonare a un
qualcosa che c'è molto vicino e cioè la
vita di una persona
perché anche la nostra vita è fatta
essenzialmente di due grandi fasi quello
in cui viviamo una certa routine
comandare tutti i giorni a scuola tutti
i giorni a lavoro all'università e
periodi in cui abbiamo dei cambiamenti
importanti delle discontinuità e possono
essere varie cose può essere la laurea
può essere un matrimonio ma lascia il
primo figlio igiene sono quelle
occasioni con indosso questo completo
comunque queste sauna di sconti da della
vita in cui noi cambiamo ed è del tutto
normale che cambiamo ci avete presente
quando si dice quella persona è cambiata
da quando si è sposato e quello sono le
disponibilità della vita solo che
siccome ne esseri umani siamo complicati
abbiamo una cosa in più che
apparentemente racconto questa
similitudine cioè il libero arbitrio la
capacità di scegliere ma realtà la sim i
to the non si rompe perché non tutte le
scelte che facciamo sono uguali non
tutte le scelte sono come sceglie il
gusto di gelato
a volte ci rendiamo conto che la nostra
vita è come se un punto di equilibrio
stabile che ha la sua routine le sue
sicurezze oggi molto parlano di zona di
comfort
però noi stamo in questa zona di confort
e potremmo renderci conto che facendo
scelte coraggiose basate molto su una
grande slancio in autostima
potremmo migliorare la nostra vita
esprime meglio il nostro potenziale
so che ci vuole un po di coraggio di
uscire dalle nostre sicurezze per
fortuna proprio perché noi abbiamo il
libero arbitrio possiamo fare questo
grande cambiamento senza dover aspettare
un fattore esterno oscillante alla
giusta frequenza ma diciamo così
possiamo posarci da sole unison anzi
evolutiva e passare da un vecchio a un
nuovo equilibrio stabile che poi avrà le
sue abitudini una sua routine e
l'assunzione di comfort e così via
per cui se questa teoria oltre a essere
scientificamente fondata dovesse anche
avere una sua forza estetica cioè se vi
piace spero davvero che abbia molta
risonanza
grazie
[Applauso]